one of the ways to test for covid-19 in
communities is through Wastewater it's
something New Brunswick's Lumen Ultra is
spearheading for the greater Toronto
Airport Authority when human beings or
really any animal gets infected with any
kind of an a infectious disease one of
the modes that we have of ridding
ourselves of that pathogen is through
poop the project will take samples of
the Wastewater to help identify variants
of concern of the Omicron Family of
covid-19 and monkey pox specifically all
areas of the airport will be a part of
the test including Wastewater on
airplanes this is a situation where an
ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
cure and part of that prevention
strategy is
continuing to monitor for the threats
that we know of and more importantly the
ones that we don't Whalen says airports
are the biggest entry point into any
country making it a critical place to
test for the presence of viruses New
Brunswick does test Wastewater for covid
in mountain and yield ground First
Nation Public Health says additional
sites for Wastewater testing have been
set up in Fredericton with sites in
Bathurst and St John's soon to follow
Dwayne McIntosh says Toronto Pearson
Airport wants to understand what viruses
are coming into the country to help
inform business and protocol decisions
first but it is willing to share with
the public health agency of Canada but
certainly we would want to make sure
that our government Partners understand
the data as well it doesn't do us any
good to work independent of the
regulators and the decision makers
Macintosh says any new variants that
could be detected through the study will
be reported Natalie sturgeon Global News
Fredericton